[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
marc fesneau bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous il est chargé
des relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne et vous êtes
également candidat aux régionales dans
votre région centre val de loire
on va bien sûr longuement parlé on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale qui représentait
justement par la presse de votre région
bonjour très soft gendry merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous dirigeant de la
nouvelle république dans le département
du loir-et-cher chère à marc fesneau
on va parler avec vous bien sûr dans
quelques instants de dossiers régionaux
christophe et de la campagne des
régionales mais d'abord l'actualité
marc chesneau et gérald darmanin qui
présente donc ce matin en conseil des
ministres un projet de loi pour
améliorer la prévention des actes
terroristes renforcement du suivi des
terroristes des outils de renseignement
ce texte il sera présenté quant au
parlement il sera présenté début juin à
l'assemblée nationale
parce que nous avons des délais qui sont
contraints en fait c'est là c'est une
nouvelle mouture du texte dit loi sylt
pour un objectif de ce qui est très bref
et très court de de lecture définitive
de vote définitif avant la fin du mois
de juillet et donc on démarre à
l'assemblée nationale au début du mois
de juin c'est un texte qui est important
parce qu'il permet de prolonger un
certain nombre de dispositifs on revient
devant le parlement
conformément à ce que la loi prévoit il
ya des clauses de revoyure et c'est bien
normal et par ailleurs ça permet
d'affiner un certain nombre de choses au
fond tirant parti de l'expérience parce
que c'est ça qui est important dans ce
dans ce genre de chose c'est des sujets
très sérieux on a malheureusement eu à
en connaître la semaine dernière et donc
il faut en permanence adapter nos outils
à la menace terroriste dont on voit
qu'elle peut évoluer parfois vers ce
qu'on appelle des loups solitaires c'est
à dire des individus dans la
radicalisation se détecte très
difficilement et souvent très tard
malheureusement et justement ça pose
plusieurs questions d'abord vous le
disais un set un taxi est prévue depuis
plusieurs semaines mais qui se
télescopent malheureusement avec
l'actualité et l'acte terroriste qui a
été commis vendredi à rambouillet est ce
que du coup le gouvernement à modifier
ce texte en conséquence
non je pense que les éléments qui sont
prévus dans ce texte le suivi des
personnes radicaliser
via la sortie d'une mesure de prison de
ces mêmes personnalités je pense que là
on a un arsenal
simplement ça appelle les affaires de
terrorisme s'appelle de la cohésion
nationale me semble-t-il parce que tout
le monde est confronté à ça et d'une
grande vigilance de tous les instants je
me permettrai de quand même de saluer le
travail des services de renseignement on
a aussi mis des moyens beaucoup plus
importants c'est plusieurs milliers
d'agents qui sont dédiés à ces tâches de
renseignement de surveillance du
territoire pour essayer de lutter pied à
pied papa contre le terrorisme il faut
le faire avec beaucoup d'humilité parce
que c'est des choses qui sont très
difficiles à faire mais en tout cas on
renforcent encore l'arsenal législatif
d'autant que vous le disais on a affaire
à des loups solitaires on l'a vu à
rambouillet en c'était un homme seul qui
n'était pas repéré par les services de
renseignement est ce que le législateur
l'exécutif sont impuissants face à ce
type de personne parce que on ne le dit
pas assez tous les actes de terroristes
ou de terrorisme plutôt qu'ils sont
évitées chaque semaine chaque mois ce
qui mène tel ou tel en grâce depuis le
début du quinquennat digérer les grandes
opérations les grandes opérations
terroristes et des gens qu'on surveille
en permanence au fond de ce point de vue
là la prévention la surveillance la
surveillance du territoire
la surveillance de ce qui se passe sur
les réseaux sociaux permet de 2
comment dirais-je de parer à ce genre
d'acte mais malheureusement on l'a
encore vu vendredi c'est une ville en
vigilance de tous les instants et donc
on a besoin de se doter de ces outils là
vous l'avez entendu de la part notamment
de la droite le débat qui revient sur le
lien entre immigration et terrorisme
est-ce que pour vous il ya un lien mais
non je trouve que faire ce lien là c'est
faire un amalgame qui me paraît
extrêmement faux et extrêmement
dangereux
la seule chose qu'il y à faire c'est de
vérifier que les personnes qui viennent
sur notre territoire il y en a certains
qui sont venus de théâtre d'opération y
compris deux théâtres d'opération qui
sont soumis à des lois du terrorisme si
je peux dire soit bien identifiée pour
qu'on puisse les renvoyer chez eux le
cas échéant et qu'on puisse en tout cas
discerner ce qui viennent pour des
raisons migratoires on à la question de
la d2 des flux migratoires à maîtriser
on s'est dotée elle a aussi d'outils
puissants depuis le début de ce
quinquennat ça veut pas dire qu'on est
au bout du chemin
on voit bien que ces décès des choses
qui sont complexes sur le contrôle aux
frontières notamment sur le contrôle aux
frontières mais on voit bien que faire
un lien entre immigration et terrorisme
c'est être dans le faux au fond et c'est
faire des amalgames qui me paraissent
très dangereux après l'important c'est
de détecter ces individus qui ne sont
pas qui ne sont pas très nombreux mais
qui sont très dangereux et qu'il faut il
qu'il faut surveiller à toute force
vallée de la politique migratoire en
décembre dernier était prévu au
parlement un débat sur la politique
migratoire il a été annulée à cause de
la crise à la place ils en débat sur la
stratégie vaccinale et il n'a jamais été
remis à l'ordre du jour ce débat est ce
que le gouvernement a peur d'un tel
débat
je crois pas qu'on ait peur d'aborder
ces questions alors sur les sujets
parfois on nous dit qu'on en fait trop
parfois on nous dit qu'on en parle trop
et là vous me dites que au fond on
aurait craint tout inquiet sur ce sujet
non c'est une question de calendrier
parlementaire
c'est à dire qu'il va être mis alors
évidemment un moment ou un autre dans le
calendrier parlementaire on remettra à
l'ordre du jour ce débat mais c'est vrai
comme vous l'avez dit que la crise
sanitaire qui est l'objet de toutes nos
préoccupations est le premier élément de
l'action du gouvernement à la fois dans
la gestion de la crise elle-même mais
aussi dans la gestion des conséquences
de la crise des conséquences économiques
et sociales la gestion de la formation
et des établissements scolaires mais le
temps viendra où on reparlera de ces
questions par le mais quand est ce que
ça sera avant l'été pas de date à vous
donner à ce stade ces parrainages et on
l'a déjà pas de belge j'ai paniqué et
j'ai pas de date à vous prêt à vous
donner à ce stade voilà on voit il ya
une offensive sécuritaire de la part d'
emmanuel macron ya ce texte est présenté
ce matin est ce que quelque part le
gouvernement cherche à corriger l'image
d'une certaine faiblesse sur le régalien
j'accepte qu'on dise tout
la vérité c'est que pendant des années
on a parlé des affaires de terrorisme
la réorganisation des services de
sécurité intérieure à des services de
lutte contre le terrorisme
la baisse des effectifs la baisse des
effectifs de police de manière continue
depuis des années avant que nous
n'arrivions ce n'est pas de l'eau à
mettre au débit du quinquennat qui ce
qui est en cours
c'est à mettre au débit de tous ceux qui
avant ne se sont pas préoccupés de ces
questions c'est plus deep mille
policiers et gendarmes qui vont être
qu'ils vont être recrutés sur le
quinquennat on tient la promesse qu'ils
étaient au rendez-vous de la de la
présidentielle de 2017 alors faut sans
doute encore déployé des moyens
supplémentaires mais venir nous dire que
nous n'aurions pas pris la mesure des
choses le président de la république a
pas pu faire un point d'étape sur un
certain nombre de dispositions on ne
découvre pas ces questions de sécurité
est loin de les découvrir en plus on
agit et donc c'est par les effectifs de
police y a pas un commissariat de france
qui ne verra pas ses effectifs de police
dans la durée du quinquennat augmenté je
pense que c'est ça c'est s'est
concrètement comment on répond c'est par
des moyens sur le terrain qui permettent
de lutter contre les actes de
délinquance ou les actes de terrorisme
l'autre texte qui est présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres le texte sur la
sortie de la crise sanitaire il sera
examiné pour le coup par les députés et
les sénateurs
dès le retour des vacances
parlementaires serait qu'il ait inscrit
le 18 mai au sénat l'assemblée ça sera
quand du coup un peu avant la semaine
d'avant la semaine du 10 mai est ce que
ça veut dire qu'on sortira de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire tel qu'on le connaît
dès le 1er juin
alors c'est un texte qui vise à la fois
mettre en place des dispositifs de
sortie comme on a connu au printemps
dernier est par ailleurs de pouvoir
disposer encore d'outils qui permettent
le cas échéant quand on voit ressurgir
un épisode épidémique dans tel ou tel
secteur dans telle ou telle région je
vous rappelle ce qui s'était passé à
marseille où ce qui avait pu se passer
dans le département de la mayenne
il faut qu'on se dote aussi même si
c'est provisoire d'outils qui permettent
quand même de faire attention à des
phénomènes épidémiques qui nous qui nous
échapperait dans tel ou tel territoire
donc c'est un une sortie type celle que
nous avons connue
le printemps dernier le cas régime
transitoire est un régime transitoire de
sortie de l'état d'urgence c'est quand
même la volonté il y aura des étapes et
des ponctuations c'est des
parlementaires qui diront il ya un
certain nombre de choses qui seront sur
des durées de l'ordre de quelques mois
évidemment la volonté du gouvernement
c'est de sortir de ce régime qui est un
régime particulier puisque c'est un
régime d'état d'urgence
on est quand même reconnaissons leur
encore dans une situation d'urgence qui
nécessite de disposer d'outils qui nous
permettent de faire face à cette crise
l'autre sujet d'actualité c'est la
sphère sarah halimi qui pose la question
de l'irresponsabilité pénale le garde
des sceaux a annoncé un projet de loi
fin mai sauf que le sénat avait déjà
inscrit son propre texte à l'ordre du
jour le 25 mai pourquoi vous n'avez pas
repris le texte du sénat et inversement
il inscrirait assez récemment à l'ordre
du jour mais comme vous le savez
communistes des relations avec le
parlement je fais en sorte que les
textes essai de cheminée 100 kg et de
compétition qui me paraissent malsaine
je les fais d'ailleurs et nous l'avons
fait sur le texte
la proposition doit billon dit billon
sur les violences sexuelles faites aux
mineurs jours qu'on a fait un travail
intelligent qui n'était pas un travail
de compétition je pense que ces sujets
sociaux la ja de texte oui très bien on
va on va on voir on va s'organiser de
faire le sénat est tout à fait dans son
droit et dans sa légitimité le
gouvernement au dessus aussi et nous
sommes pas tout à fait sans doute sur
les mêmes dispositions législatives
l'important c'est qu'on trouve au fond
une réponse à un sujet qui est très très
difficile c'est le sujet de à partir de
quel moment juste que quelqu'un était
responsable et à partir de quel moment
au fond on laisse les victimes sans
réponse pénale
et c'est bien ça la difficulté alors
l'alternance n'est pas question de
remettre en cause en soit la question de
l'irresponsabilité
il ya un certain nombre de cas où on a
pu provoquer une certaine façon par le
fait de d'absorber des substances des
substances illicites
on a pu provoquer ça une forme
d'irresponsabilité mental il faut qu'on
y travaille c'est des sujets le la cour
de cassation a dit le droit
et manifestement le droit n'est pas
satisfaisant parce que moi je comprends
très légitimement l'émotion qui est
suscitée par le fait au fond qu'on se
contente de dire la personne n'était pas
responsable et donc vous n'aurez pas le
droit même un procès qu'ils puissent
débattre de ce qui s'est passé et de ce
qui s'est passé en termes pénales donc
moi je crois que le gouvernement
travaille on travaillera avec le sénat
ils ont un texte
on verra le gouvernement travaille
soutiendrez le texte du sénat
on a vous permettrait au gouvernement
d'avoir ses propres
comment dirais-je son propre champ
d'investigation on peut trouver des
compromis on l'a trouvé sur la ppl
billon on l'a trouvée sur de bien
d'autres textes avec le sénat et il me
semble que tout ça est ce qu'il ya de
plus normal on est sur des sujets
suffisamment sensible pour pas qu'on en
fasse une querelle politicienne et une
chorale politique entre le sénat où
l'assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
je suis sûr qu'on trouvera les voies et
moyens pour trouver un chemin
un dernier mot sur le plan de relance
puisque la france transmet ce matin sa
feuille de route à bruxelles
objectif toucher les 40 milliards du
fonds européen on a vu hier bruno le
maire olivier dussopt devant les
parlementaires est ce que le parlement
il sera consultée sur sa feuille de
route à ce qu un débat là-dessus il ya
le que le parlement est toujours associé
à la feuille de route parce que c'est
une feuille de route aussi budgétaire
qui est donné au parlement est par
nature et par construction le parlement
est associée l'assemblée nationale et
sénat c'est l'iran débat spécifique sur
siagne abri d un débat spécifique alors
soit c'est en commission soit 7 en
séance publique mais il ya un débat
spécifique sur ce qu'on appelle la
stabilité le et ligne de stabilité
budgétaire et donc évidemment et il est
normal puisque ça déjà fait des 1 relève
du champ budgétaire que le parlement
puisse être informés et puissent
débattre lui-même des perspectives
budgétaires que donne que donne la
nation française et l'union européenne
on va passer à la crise sanitaire
c'était votre premier déplacement de
campagne imprimée sanitaire marc
chesneau et on va en parler avec
christophe gendre et oui de loi est
actuellement une des régions les plus
touchées par l'épidémie que les dix-neuf
les services de réanimation des hôpitaux
au delà la saturation qu'est ce que
cette crise 10 de notre système de santé
est tel rôle sur la région peut-elle
jouer pour participer à ces réseaux
mafieux alors elle dit peter plusieurs
choses est d'abord bonjour elle dit
plusieurs choses de de la situation du
pays
d'abord sans doute que nous n'étions pas
collectivement préparer à une faire face
à une crise sanitaire comme celle là
mais en même temps que le système
sanitaire a pu s'adapter
le printemps dernier et comme ils
s'adaptent là vous avez raison de
souligner que les hôpitaux sont en sur
serre tueur saturation en région centre
val de loire
je pense que pour le coup là il ya une
grande part qui relève de l'organisation
de l'état ce que j'aurai salue aussi
c'est qu'on a pu mettre en place
comment dirais-je d'une forme de
fluidité entre le privé et le public
qu'on a pu mettre en place une forme de
nouvelles formes d'organisation entre la
médecine dite de ville et la médecine
hospitalière et que tout ça fait un tour
on le voit d'ailleurs aussi dans la
politique vaccinale vont permettre et
quand même au passage de saluer j'étais
effectivement ça a été le choix de mon
premier déplacement parce qu'on est en
crise sanitaire c'est une crise qui est
très difficile pour les soignants pour
ceux évidemment qu'ils sont malades de
saluer toutes celles et ceux qui
travaillent alors après il ya un
deuxième sujet sans doute en région
centre val de loire qui est très
spécifique c'est le sujet médical et
démographie médicale sur lequel la
région peut peut agir ce que je constate
parce qu'il faut aussi parler du bilan
c'est que depuis dix ans la situation
s'est plus dégradée qu'ailleurs en
région centre val de loire ce que je
constate c'est que en région centre val
de loire il n'y a que 13 % des votes des
citoyens de cette région qui ont accès
plus de quatre fois un médecin par an
quand en france la moyenne est à 30 de
plus de 30% 33% de tête alors il suffit
pas de dire je vais faire je vais dire
je vais salariés des médecins parce
qu'au fond les grandes annonces sont une
chose mais concrètement sur le
territoire il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui n'ont pas de médecin référent
il ya des réponses qui peuvent exister
les maisons de santé pluridisciplinaires
mais la maison de santé des restes et
pluridisciplinaire nak n'a salle est
financé par la région et l'état
d'ailleurs au passage elle n'a un sens
que si à l'intérieur on arrive à y
trouver des médecins
donc il faut faire feu de tout bois si
je peux dire je dis quand même au
passage que c'est tout ça c'est si on
est héritier d'une situation qui est
celle d'agde delà d'avoir restreint le
numerus clausus ont l'art est ouvert
cola mais vous voyez bien que le numerus
clausus il produira ses effets que dans
7 8 10 ans et donc il ya un travail dans
l'intervalle affaire d'organisation les
comités les communautés territoriales de
santé sont des outils qui se permettent
de lier les professionnels avec les
collectivités d'essayer de travailler et
donc il faut travailler sur l'ensemble
des sujets je donne un autre une autre
voix me semble utile que j'ai vécu dans
ma propre commune c'est la question de
l'accès aux stages des internes
quand vous avez des internes qui font
auprès de praticiens de ville médecins
libéraux ils découvrent le métier il
découvre le territoire et ils ont envie
de s'y installer parce que
l'installation des médecins s'est pas
seulement la formation de médecins
l'installation des médecins c'est la
capacité d'attractivité du territoire
les garder une fois qu'ils sont formés
parce qu'une fois qu'ils sont formés ils
peuvent s'installer partout en france et
donc le sujet n'est pas seulement
que nous ayons beaucoup plus de médecins
qui soient formées pour la médecine
générale mais c'est que nous fassions en
sorte qu'ils aient envie de rester et y
installer il suffit pas de dire j'ai
fait une maison et ça suffit le
président de la région sortante a
indiqué qu'il allait depuis plusieurs
mois même voire années a dit qu'il
allait salariés des médecins ça se
compte sur les doigts de deux mains
peut-être le nombre de médecins qui sont
salariés donc les grandes annonçant
qu'une chose le concret est une chose
plus plus importante en tout cas pour
ceux qui ont envie de se soigner bien
une des conséquences de ces crises c'est
la fermeture de commerces est également
de bon touristique
comment expliquer aujourd'hui tout ce
qui était très forte dans la région sans
maître de l'horreur comment expliquer
que les châteaux les jardins les
androïdes l'espace et où la
distanciation physique puis saisi à
respecter comme expliqué que ces
châteaux soit toujours fermée
aujourd'hui pour une raison simple c'est
que ce qu'on a appris du virus en
particulier des variants qui sont
beaucoup plus contaminant c'est que il
ya la fois l'hélios qu'on se contaminent
puis les moments d'interaction plus vous
multipliez les moments d'interaction et
c'est vrai que vous avez moins de
chances d'attraper chances entre
guillemets de mal chance d'attraper le
virus dans un lieu extérieur que dans un
lieux intérieurs
sauf que quand vous mettez en mouvement
des tas de gens c'est bien les principes
de la des règles qui ont été établies
depuis quelques semaines
plus vous mettez en interaction les gens
plus vous leur faites prendre des
risques plus ou multiplier les chenilles
les interactions entre les citoyens plus
vous avez de rivedoux les mesures qui
sont qui sont effectués mais pour
essayer de répondre plus avant à votre
question évidemment l'objectif c'est que
c'est lui là soient les premiers ouverts
vous avez raison de le dire et vous
connaissez très bien cette région c'est
une région où les lieux touristiques les
jardins les châteaux sont des lieux ouf
on peut avoir le sentiment d'être plus
en sécurité donc dès lors qu'on va
libérer la question des distances à
partir desquels on peut on peut se
déplacer dès lors que la vaccination
continue à progresser j'étais aussi et
dans un centre de vaccination olivier la
semaine prochaine on peut espérer que
les choses sont importantes
nous avons vécu dans notre région dans
mon département du loir-et-cher dans
notre département du loir-et-cher année
tu es où
au fond on a vu un afflux très
significatif de touristes venant de
notre région mais aussi venant des
autres régions parce que on voit bien
que c'est une forme de tourisme qui est
moins un tourisme de masse et qui
correspond aux besoins du moment et aux
contraintes du moment et donc on peut
espérer qu'avec toutes ces mesures on
puisse avoir un été qui soit plus
conforme à ce qu'on en est on
ce qu'on souhaite on va parler
d'agriculture christophe oui alors marc
raynaud et du maire de marchenoir jésus
dieu comme une personne que je connais
sa sensibilité aux questions et liqueurs
justement la raison de la pac provoque
une vive inquiétude dans les campagnes
en ce moment position à ce sujet qu'est
ce que vous avez à dire aux agriculteurs
on sait qu'ils peuvent internationale
libérer des normes ou alors imposé alors
deux choses sur la politique agricole
commune sans rentrer trop dans la
technique il ya deux piliers ya le
premier pilier qui est le pilier plutôt
économique puis le deuxième pilier qui
est plutôt le pilier développement rural
sur le pilier économique la principale
inquiétude je crois qu'on est en train
d'élever il ya des règles de ce qu'on
appelle écoconditionnalité les échos
régime qui qui doivent permettre aux
agriculteurs d'assumer des transitions
qui leur sont demandés qui sont des
transitions extrêmement difficile mais
en même temps il faut que le maximum
d'agriculteurs puisse y avoir accès pour
qu'ils puissent avoir accès et
puissances engagées dans cette
transition écologique ça c'est un
premier point de vigilance
nous discutons beaucoup avec julien de
normandie sur ce sujet je pense que sur
ces sujets là on va pouvoir avancer
positivement deuxième point le de ce
qu'on appelle 2e pilier le volet
développement rural sur ce volet
développement rural structurellement
cette région est moins dotées que les
autres
la répartition des enveloppes peut-être
qui a été fait depuis des années a été
une répartition qui s'est fait en
défaveur de la région centre val de
loire alors il appartient aussi au
gouvernement mais il appartient aussi au
président de la région en ce moment en
place de discuter avec ses homologues
des autres régions pour expliquer que
notre région en particulier ces zones
intermédiaires
je pense au sud du département du loir
et cher et je pense au sud de notre
région pour faire un axe nord-sud
séparés par la loi on a besoin d'outils
de développement rural qui permettent de
maintenir des activités je pense par
exemple à des activités d'élevage mais
aussi par exemple des activités de
polyculture donc tout l'enjeu
d'un président de région et c'est celui
là que je veux êtres c'est de faire en
sorte que on défende les intérêts de la
région et qu'on ne soit pas les bras
ballants le nom du chemin à dire ah
c'est pas de notre faute c'est les
autres n'ont plus de moyens je pense
qu'il faut se battre au niveau national
c'est ce que je fais pour ma part comme
ministre mais aussi comme élus de ce
territoire de faire en sorte que cette
région puissent se voir doter de moyens
qui lui permettent d'assurer les
transitions par esor les mesures agri
environnementales et puis troisième
chose la concurrence nous sommes dans
une concurrence mondiale et une
concurrence européenne ne faudrait pas
non plus qu'on organise une concurrence
intra régional si à toutes ces normes
qui sont parfois difficiles et le
gouvernement essaie de ne pas en
rajouter on rajoute des normes
régionales qui font que au fond mais
déboulé supplémentaire au pied des
agriculteurs région centre val de loire
par rapport à leurs voisins à leurs
homologues du bassin parisien des pays
de loire alors là on fait défaut et on
voit bien que les équilibres politiques
qui ont été tenus dans cette région il
vise à chaque fois la seule réponse
qu'on fait c'est mon normalise ont fait
la contrainte supplémentaire et on dit
ça va bien aller comme ça sauf qu'on
crée une distorsion de concurrence entre
les territoires de la région et moi je
pense qu'il faut accompagner les
transitions il faut pas les accompagner
par la contrainte je connais bien le
monde agricole vous avez raison c'est un
monde qui est prêt à bouger mais pas pas
de la façon dont les choses sont faites
est ce que la région a plus avancé
depuis des années avec cette méthode là
la réponse est non christophe on va
parler un domaine important pour la
région c'est l'économie oui tout à fait
et en os domaine économique justement le
notre région est très impliqué
logistique mais aussi la sous traitance
automobile ou aéronautique alors elle
est ce que ça peut se conjuguer
si on le long terme avec les enjeux
environnementaux et dans le même
registre est votre position sur les
subventions de la région apporter aux
héros pendant que châteauroux et tours
cplt lui la présidence est ce que vous
faites là dre ces subventions
ah oui parce que là pour le coup faut
pas tergiverser parce que je vois bien
que l'exécutif en place tergiverse parce
qu'il a des contingences avec les
écologistes l'aéronautique et
l'automobile c'est une chance pour
l'économie de notre région
nous sommes la deuxième ou troisième
région de sous traitance aéronautique la
part de l'aéronautique dans le
réchauffement climatique
c'est moins de 3% par ailleurs
l'aviation est en train de faire sa
mutation y compris avec les moteurs à
hydrogène les moteurs électriques et
déjà à la consommation énergétique parce
que c'est l'intérêt des avionneurs
d'ailleurs et de réduire sa consommation
et donc cette espèce de modèles qu'on
essaie de nous vend
qui est un modèle anti voitures anti
avions alors je sais qu'on n'a même plus
le droit de rêver d'avion -un et bientôt
nous explique qu'on n'a même plus le
droit d'avoir son permis de conduire
c'est une question de rêve mais c'est
plus qu'une question de rêve c'est une
question de développement économique
qu'est ce qu'on dit aux salariés qu il
n'y a plus d'avenir à la voiture on a à
blois décide très prestigieux en termes
automobiles qui ont essayé qui essayent
à toute force d' accélérer les mutations
en travaillant par exemple sur
l'hydrogène dans une région comme les
nôtres on a besoin de ces emplois on a
besoin de la voiture
ça veut pas dire qu'on est pas pour la
transition de la voiture qu'on doit pas
faire un choix vers l'électrique qu'on
doit pas faire un choix vers l'hydrogène
et donc on a absolument besoin de 2,2 de
soutenir ces industries aéronautique et
ses industries automobiles quant à tours
et châteauroux il faut fermement
défendre ces deux plateformes
aéroportuaires qui ont des tours des
vocations différentes la plate forme de
château a plutôt une vocation de
maintenance aéronautique et la plate
forme de tour est plutôt sur le voyage
mais là aussi faut avoir une politique
qui soit claire il y en a un peu assez
de d'une politique qui se fait à la
corbeille des accords par partisans et
on a besoin d'une politique soient
claires et déterminées transition
écologique et en même temps une capacité
économique et capacités de développement
pour cette région parce que c'est les
deux peuvent se mener de pair j'en suis
absolument certain quand j'étais
vice-président du syndicat d'énergie du
loir et cher on a développé les bornes
électriques sur le département du loir
et cher il faut sans doute encore
accéléré ces processus donc je ne me
ferai pas enfermer dans des les gens qui
nous donnent des leçons et qui ont fait
on fait beaucoup moins beaucoup parlé on
fait assez peu et pour terminer
christophe a parlé de la campagne
électorale à proprement parler oui alors
lors de ces régionales pour aller
chercher une lutte au second tour il
faudra des alliances avant tout les cas
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
travailler dans le futur avec la liste
il y avait dix listes où il faut le
rappeler laquelle vous étiez associés il
ya six ans puisqu'à l'époque vous étiez
d'ailleurs le colistier de l'émission le
riche à waco par alou est ce qu'une
entente est possible avec françois
bonneau le président sortant quels sont
vos axes de travail
alors d'abord je vois les listes qui
fleurissent che mais fleury chez mes
concurrents je vois beaucoup des listes
des tickets talents multiples il est
parti à des listes avec huit ou dix
parties
on essaie de faire des quotas ils font
un troisième manifestement il faut que
le parti communiste soit troisième sur
la liste de monsieur bono donc à une
forme de quotas moi je ne constituerait
pas une liste parti m je fais partie de
la majorité présidentielle je défends le
gouvernement j'ai pas besoin de le
répéter 25 fois par jour mais c'est une
certitude et une réalité j'assume ce que
je suis deuxième élément je suis du
modem et je les assume depuis des années
comme vous le savez j'ai fait d'ailleurs
dans des situations de risque
j'entendais à votre antenne monsieur
bono qui donnait des leçons et qui
disait c'est une voie de secours pour un
ministre il cherche à toute force à
rester en place alors que ça 25
ça fait 25 ans qui sont en situation de
changer de la région et que
manifestement il n'y ont pas réussi
moi je prends mon risque j'ai décidé
d'essayer de mettre mes compétences mon
expertise nationale et locale au service
de la région c'est bien ça qui comptait
deux mois je ne me préoccupe pas de ces
questions dagnan de second tour et
d'équilibrage voit bien qu'un certain
nombre de gens font des listes avec
cette préoccupation ma préoccupation
c'est de sortir en tête et ma
préoccupation c'est d'offrir aux
habitants une alternative à ce débat que
certains voudraient construire et de
faire en sorte qu'une nouvelle majorité
sortent de la région et donc c'est les
électeurs qui décideront de ce qui se
passe le soir du premier tour et plus
nous placerons au plus on sera en
situation de pouvoir gagner et dernière
question
la citc internationale ce qui est lé
seul on joue aux mesures du champ voulu
l'échiquier cette région
ben le rassemblement national dans cette
région et je rappelle que la dernière
fois il était au dessus de 30
autant me souvienne premier au deuxième
tour il est en mesure évidemment de
bouleverser l'échiquier il n'est pas en
mesure en revanche de répondre aux
problèmes quotidiens des citoyens la
région centre val de loire et moi je je
comprends absolument les colères je vois
ce qui se sentent délaissés les
territoires qui ont eu l'impression
d'être totalement abandonnés depuis des
années mais les qu'il n'y a pas de
solution dans le solutions concrètes à
ce qu'offre le front national c'est un
c'est un vote qui exprime une colère la
réponse qu'il faudra qu'on apporte l'eau
c'est une réponse concrète pour que les
gens ne venaient plus cette colère et
vivent différemment sur nos territoires
a rapidement marqué depuis ce qu'on lit
ce matin dans le figaro vous pour faire
campagne ou à les déployer des faits
nous mobile qu'est ce que c'est c'est
pas moi qui ai donné surnom mais je vois
le surnom qui est donné
la volonté c'est bien qu'on est dans une
campagne qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
faire de rassemblements publics et je
compte bien me conformer à cette règle
mais je pense que du coup il faut aller
à la rencontre des citoyens et la
volonté que nous avons au travers de six
véhicules qui tourneront dans chacun des
départements dans quelques jours de
faire ensemble d'aller à la rencontre
dans les villes et les villages des
citoyens pour leur exposer nos
programmes qui leur phase nous fassent
part de leurs récriminations de leurs
propositions de leur réaction parce
qu'on va leur proposer aux français faut
qu'on aille à eux puisque c'est plus
difficile qu'ils viennent à nous et donc
c'est une façon nouvelle moderne et puis
c'est une façon de montrer que c'est
comme pour les services c'est comme des
tas de choses il faut aller au coeur des
territoires il faut pas demander
simplement aux gens de se déplacer vers
nous merci beaucoup merci rufino d'avoir
été notre invité merci christophe gendry
d'avoir été avec lyon pour cette
interview on passe aussitôt club des
territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale la
mutuelle des agents des services publics
merci christophe gembrie d'avoir été
avec nous